Film Courage: Why did it take years for this
film [THE VANISHING OF SIDNEY HALL] to be
made?
Shawn Christensen, co-screenwriter/director:
We had the film optioned and then bought out
by a really great independent producer and
a great director.
And then they couldn’t get the money together
or something and we were just kind of poor
kids sitting around waiting for them to do
something.
And then it just kind of…they bought it
out because they thought they were going to
make it and they didn’t and then it got
stuck at Fox.
After awhile they all left Fox and Fox (the
studio itself) didn’t realize they even
had this screenplay.
So it was a little loophole with the WGA (The
Writers Guild) about getting your screenplay
back.
Most people (I should say) don’t get their
screenplays back but this particular screenplay,
it’s a small script or it’s a small premise
and we thought we had a shot at buying it
back for the price we sold it for (which was
not very much).
And we asked Fox if they would give it back
to us and you know they did.
They gave it back to us for basically the
price that we bought it for and we went and
made it.
But we had to wait with that clause, with
that WGA clause, you have to wait 5 years.
You have to wait 5 years after the last rewrite
or the last active…(it’s called Active
Development) and a studio will find any way
they can to not give you back your script.
Active Development can be misconstrued as
anything.
I mean that could be…a lunch.
I mean they could say anything.
That’s not really illegal, it’s so loose,
you know?
But Fox, simply put they just didn’t know
that the screenplay was in their vault because
the people who had brought it in and left
and we got it back.
Film Courage: Did you lay awake at night thinking
“I want this screenplay back” or it was
more a process where it came at the right
time (the five years was up)?
Shawn Christensen: It was more in the back
of my head.
When I had heard about this WGA clause (the
five-year thing) which was like a couple months
after we had done a quick rewrite on it, I
kind of just set my internal back-of-my-head
timer and Jason Dolan (the co-screenwriter),
we just kind of set it in our heads that whenever
it was (2016 I think it was) we are able to
reacquire the screenplay and by that time
I think I had just made my first feature and
I was able to attract more interest to make
a second feature and so the timing was right
on it.
But really to be truthful I actually didn’t
necessarily want to make the movie, I just
wanted the script back.
But…we made it.